hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to 2015. so 2014 was a pretty
awesome year in a lot of ways i uploaded
93 new videos during those 52 weeks
which were watched more than 130 million
times
we passed 1 million and 2 million
subscribers on the channel which is
awesome and i think the most
mind-blowing statistic since my videos
are so long on average a little more
than seven minutes normally the total
amount of time that was spent watching
the videos that i made in the last year
is more than a thousand years of human
life
jeez i think my favorite video that i
got to make this past year last year i
say last year a lot uh was the
smartphone awards 2014 video it was a
fun unique thing to close out the year
it was one of the latest ones uh and i
literally just got to pick my favorite
phone from much categories best camera
best budget etc so that was awesome but
yeah i got to be a part of a lot of
other memorable videos and i got to make
a bunch of other memorable videos during
the year as well so it was pretty
awesome so 2014 is going to be a pretty
tough act to follow but what better way
to get it kicked off than of course with
ces so ces if you didn't know is the
consumer electronic show that's in las
vegas every january where tons of people
go to check out the latest technology
and i'll again be trying to find the
coolest stuff there this is what i do
every year i don't cover like everything
i don't run around with the camera and
try to make a thousand videos but when i
do find something cool i will tweet
about it and if it's really cool i'll
make a video about it so this is the
time where i'll actually be depending on
the tweets you guys send me of what you
want to see videos of
and that's the stuff that i'll go and
try to find also i guess this is your
annual reminder to set up email
notifications for new uploads if you
want to because if you're subscribed to
a bunch of other tech channels this time
of year you're inevitably going to get a
flood of videos in your sub box so to
make sure you see mine you can go and
sign up for email notifications so every
time i upload a new video get a nice
little email in your inbox with a pretty
thumbnail and you'll be able to click
and watch from there so definitely hit
me up on twitter if you guys find stuff
or if you think of things that you want
to see me do videos on predictions for
ces mine would be pretty tame this year
i'm thinking we're going to see a lot of
4k tvs and i think this is going to be
the first year we see a lot of
beyond 4k tvs so we see a lot of 4k and
last year we saw one or two 8k tvs i
think we're actually going to see a
surprising amount more of
6k 8k and even higher super high
resolution tvs this year that's just my
prediction and we'll see more wearables
i think 2014 was all the year of these
first gen wearables
so we're going to see some more of that
uh at the show this time and since this
is about 2015 i want to talk about a
couple things that are coming soon one a
website i've only tweeted about this a
couple of times but if you've gone to
mkbhd.com you'll see that it is uh being
made it's in a process right now and
it's taken longer than i thought of
course websites tend to do that but i
want to get it right so this is sort of
a
new thing that's going to be happening
during 2015. and also obviously some
awesome videos that i've been teasing a
little bit but haven't gotten the chance
to finish and upload so some of the
things that you've seen like various
screenshots from and things that have
been teased i know i said 2014 is going
to be a tough fact to follow but i think
a lot of the content that's in the
pipeline for like even the first few
weeks of 2015 are going to be up to the
task so this is just a quick video
saying happy new year to everyone who
makes this stuff possible and my new
year's resolution is to make every new
video my best work and that might not
mean i make a ton of videos obviously i
don't make a thousand videos every month
or anything like that but i think every
new project is an opportunity to do your
best work and hopefully i can do that in
2015. thank you for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
so this is just a quick video saying
happy new year to everyone who's in
2015.
what